one of the most extreme lies about  transgender people in the current era is  that we wish to trick or force  children into getting surgeries that  will irrevocably alter their bodies  here's the thing that is depressingly  hilarious about that  doctors are making these kinds of  decisions and performing surgeries on  not only children but infants frequently  when they encounter an intersex child  and decide that should either be a boy  or a girl and they will then perform a  surgery  on a child who has no choice and is  perfectly healthy cis people the only  ones who are forcing children to have  surgeries over their gender is you